hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
early on in his passes Pascal is going
to have a long section titled
imagination it's number 82 in the brunch
fig edition of the text and it has to do
with the power of this human faculty
over that of another human faculty that
is reason what we typically associate
with human beings and Pascal is making
the case that imagination plays a much
greater role in human Affairs than
reason does and that it's actually
reasonable to a certain extent to not
just be wary of imagination but actually
as we're going to see to take on some of
its lessons and he follows this section
82 with a little remark at the beginning
of section 83 which says we must thus
begin the chapter on the deceptive
powers and then in 84 and 85 as we'll
see he comes back to imagination and the
deceptive powers that he talks about
there are sense and reason there's a lot
of ways in which we can go wrong and it
begins in section 82 this discussion of
imagination by telling us it is that
deceitful deceptive part of the human
being that Mistress of error and falsity
the more deceptive that she is not
always so and so we've got a little bit
of a paradox here at the beginning
imagination we could say is not even
reliably deceitful about truth if it
were as Pascal points out well then we
could just like essentially use what we
call reverse psychology right she he
says that imagination would be an
infallible rule of truth if it were an
infallible rule of falsehood but being
most generally false
she imagination gives no sign of her
nature and how so by as he says
impressing markanth but placing a mark
upon the same character on the true as
it does the false so imagination unlike
reason doesn't help us separate out the
true from the false it just presents
them all kind of willy-nilly and maybe
we buy into some things that aren't true
as if they are true and we Overlook some
things as being false and and so on
right it could be that everything we
imagine actually is true although highly
doubtful
we would never know that's part of the
problem
and he goes on and he says that
I'm not speaking of fools I'm actually
speaking of the wisest men the blue size
right and he says it is among them that
imagination has the great gift of
persuasion reason protests in vain it
cannot set a hear the translation a True
Value P right it doesn't actually have
the word true in there but we could read
that in reason can't set a True Value
onto things onto matters like shows in
French right so reason is unable to
determine for us what everything
literally should cost or should be
exchanged for although it pretends that
it can
and he goes out and he talks about the
the relationship between reason and
Imagination right so reason you know can
get very upset uh you can have somebody
like Descartes Pascal's contemporary
who's like I don't trust imagination you
know pure uh cognition reasoning
thinking that's what it's all about and
Pascal's saying oh buddy that's just not
the way it works not just for ordinary
people but even for the wise so many of
our decisions and our ideas are being
given to us by this faculty of the
imagination which then he tells us likes
to rule and the French word for that is
kontole right so rule uh does work for
that it likes it it implies not just
giving direction to but uh a
busybodyness you could say hey getting
into it it's uh it's a micromanager of
reason and it also likes to dominate
dominate reason as well so imagination
isn't just doing it's it's work on its
own as a separate faculty from reason
it likes to take over it likes to run
the show Pascal is pointing out and he
goes on and he says that it is
established in man a second nature to
show how all-powerful
she that is imagination is
a second nature now that's an
interesting thing to say and that
hearkens back to you know a much earlier
discussion of second nature very famous
one coming from Aristotle where he's
telling us that habits are really second
nature and that's not false but
imagination also working together with
habits as we're going to see in just a
few minutes with some of the examples
tends to produce in us this what he's
calling second nature and why is it
important that it's a second nature it's
not our originary nature but it's the
nature that we live in day by day so
what does it do uh he tells us she makes
men happy and sad healthy and sick rich
and poor now happy and sad okay that's
very easy to understand with imagination
Now isn't it but
healthy and sick well you know we know
that there is a mind-body connection and
you know we can also talk about mental
illness as well and then rich and poor
isn't that an interesting one can
imagination actually add zeros to the
end of the the numbers in your checking
account or you know whatever other
electronic things you have well it can
that's illusory but it can make you feel
rich it can also make you feel poorer
when you're comparing yourself against
others
um he goes on she compels reason to
believe doubt and deny so that's part of
that domination Factor right and then uh
he says she blunts the senses or
quickens them so it's not just reason
that imagination works on it's also our
sense perception of things and he goes
on she has her fools and sages nothing
vexes us more than to see that she fills
her devotees with a satisfaction and
just you know in French satisfaction
right that is uh more full and ample or
entire than does reason
those who have a lively imagination he
says are a great deal more pleased with
themselves than the wise can reasonably
be they look down upon men with
haughtiness they argue with boldness and
confidence others with fear and
diffidence those who rely on reason who
are more in touch with reality are less
confident about things right fear and
diffidence those who are you know
um convinced that they're in the know
about things that they're powerful that
everybody thinks they're they're a cool
guy or something like that they're much
more confident as a result of this
imagining
and he goes on and says this gives them
an advantage in the opinion of the
hearers such favor have the imaginary
wise in the eyes of judges of like
nature imagination cannot make fools
wise but she can make them happy to the
Envy of Reason which can only make its
friends miserable and you know now
Pascal doesn't know about social media
but just think about this think about
influencers right and how full of crap
most of them turn out to be right if you
look closely if you look reasonably at
them but how easy it is to get swept up
in the imagination of oh this person is
smart ooh this person is ethical oh this
person is pick whatever you like right
they come out with confidence and we
like a bunch of dummies and suckers
believe them
right or we believe they're opposites
you know contrarianism and he's going to
give a whole bunch of examples here he
says what but this faculty of
imagination dispenses reputation Awards
respect and veneration to persons Works
laws and the great how insufficient are
all the riches of the earth without her
consent and then uh he he talks about
this very interesting case of a
magistrate so what's a magistrate you
know an official this magistrate whose
age commands the respect of a whole
people would you not say that this
person is governed by pure and lofty
reason and that he judges causes
according to their true nature without
considering those mere Trifles which
only affect the imagination of the weak
and now notice it it's quite interesting
he doesn't say hey consider the
philosopher he talks about the
magistrate the person of practical
affairs who has to engage in judgments
not about abstract things but about the
day-to-day and the uh you know
complicated mundane things that people
are in Conflict about now that person
presumably is quite reasonable
and driven my reason and then he says
he's going to go and listen to a sermon
now you know going to listen to a sermon
was something that a lot of people did
whether they believed or not it was part
of the culture of the time and a lot of
people quite specialized in giving good
sermons there's like an entire art to it
right so he's he's as Pascal says he's
ready to listen with exemplary respect
but let the preacher appear let nature
have given him a hoarse voice or a
comical cast of countenance or let his
Barber have given him a bad shave let by
chance his dress be more dirty than
usual then however great the truths he
announces I wager our Senator loses his
gravity right so imagination makes it
difficult for this person to take the
person seriously and take what they're
saying seriously then he's got an
example about the philosopher and a
plank if the greatest philosopher in the
world found himself on a plank wider
than actually necessary but hanging over
a precipice there's a gulf below he
could fall
his imagination will prevail even though
his reason convince him of his safety
many cannot bear the thought without a
cold sweat he says and then he goes out
and talks about other things that tend
to derange the reason he says that you
know everyone knows that the sight of
cats or rats the crushing of a coal man
hinge the reason the tone of voice
affects the wisest and changes the force
of a discourse or a poem and then he
talks about Justice lover hate Alters
the aspect of Justice when we're judging
we you know tend to overlook things with
the people that we like we tend to focus
in very closely on any criticisms that
can be made of people that we dislike he
goes on as well and says how much
greater confidence has an advocate a
lawyer right retained with a large fee
in the Justice of his cause getting a
big fat fee makes you feel good good and
then you're like I'm gonna do a good job
here right and then people believe you
all due to the power of the imagination
and he goes on as well and says that how
ludicrous is reason blown with a breath
in every direction and then he goes out
and says
I should have to enumerate that is you
know write a whole table of almost every
action of human beings who scarce waiver
save under her assaults if we wanted to
expand it we could say just about every
Human Action is going to be liable to
being influenced by imagination both for
the doer and perhaps the sufferer or the
benefit the benefited person right and
for any sort of Spectators and he goes
on and he says reason has been obliged
to yield so you know we're going to
derive something from this in a moment
but there's two other examples that I
think would be worth bringing up so one
comes up in section 84 and 85
um
he says the imagination enlarges little
objects so as to fill our souls with a
fantastic estimate and with rash
insolence it belittles the great to its
own measure as when talking of God so
when it comes to Greatness and
littleness of things it takes little
things makes them really important and
then takes very big things and tries to
bring them down to our level he goes on
and says things which have most hold on
us as the concealment of our few
possessions are often a mere nothing it
is a nothing which our imagination
magnifies into a mountain another turn
of the imagination would make us
discover this without difficulty so once
again imagination is rather deceiving us
he's got another important discussion
where he is focusing in on this this
faculty that he calls the heart and this
is uh not far from the famous reason in
the heart has its reasons that reason is
not familiar with part right he says
that um
men often take their imagination
for their heart they believe they are
converted
as soon as they think of being converted
so they imagine being converted they
imagine a change in not just life and
mind and actions but in the inward part
of their AFF activity in the very Spirit
itself that we call the heart in Pascal
imagination can counterfeit that right
so coming back to reason right he
actually says something very interesting
here
he tells us that
reason has been obliged to yield the
wisest reason the plusage right takes as
her own principles
what what it is that the imagination of
man has everywhere rashly introduced
right without thinking too much so this
is actually uh quite important here
right he says that the person who would
follow reason only would be deemed
foolish by the generality of human
beings
we must judge by the opinion of the
majority of mankind because it has
pleased them we must work all day for
pleasure seem to be imaginary and after
sleep has refreshed our tired reason we
must forthwith startup and Rush effort
after Phantoms and suffer the
impressions of the mistresses of the
world this is one of the sources of
error but it's not the only one so
imagination can be deceptive imagination
tries to dominate reason reason can even
though it's weaker than imagination not
quite get the upper hand but at least
prudently rely upon it and here's a
prime example of this Pascal is going to
discuss at considerable length what
happens in terms of what we might call
Pomp and Circumstance symbolic uh Garb
Arrangements architecture all these
sorts of things so he tells us that our
magistrates again people who are in
charge have well known this mystery the
red robes the ermine in which they wrap
themselves like furry cats the courts in
which they administer Justice the
fleur-de-lis and all this August apparel
were necessary
right and then he talks about Physicians
if the Physicians had not their
Catholics and their mules if the doctors
had not their Square caps and their
robes four times to wide you know he's
talking about Scholars there they would
never have duped the world which cannot
resist so original an appearance and
then he says
if magistrates had True Justice and if
Physicians had the true art of healing
they would have no occasion for square
caps the Majesty of these Sciences would
of itself be venerable enough but having
only imaginary knowledge they must
employ those silly tools that strike the
imagination with which they have to deal
and thereby in fact they Inspire respect
Is this different in our time what
happens when you go to court there's all
sorts of ceremony things are you know
not of course in you know robes and
irmine and stuff like that although you
know in the British places they have to
wear those those uh wigs and that's
that's part of what's going on there but
there's an entire like ceremonial
function to it you don't go into court
just dressed in a t-shirt or something
like that you wear a shirt and tie and
perhaps a jacket right there's ways in
which things are done we can say this
about medicine now medicine has made
some great advances since Pascal's time
but there's still something about
somebody wearing a white coat and having
a stethoscope that inspires a kind of
confidence that coming in and flip-flops
and shorts wouldn't necessarily do I
mean we put people on TV and dress them
up like doctors and then we believe in
them as a result and we could say this
about so many other professions as well
there's an imaginary power at work and
then Pascal is actually going to
contrast this against Kings people who
have real power power over life and
death he says our Kings seek out no
disguises they do not mask themselves in
extraordinary costumes to appear such
they're accompanied instead by guards
and halberdiers right and who else does
he say doesn't have to hide behind
things soldiers
he says that soldiers alone are not
disguised in this manner their part is
the most essential they establish
themselves by force the others by show
now we could of course talk about the
wild imaginary that so many people in
our own time live in when it comes to
soldiers because they've watched too
many movies and shows and played too
much Call of Duty or other games and
things like that and that's all in their
head and that leads them to saying
stupid things about ongoing offensives
that we see happening or what it what
it's like to be a tough guy Soldier you
know as opposed to being in a woke
military or something like that and they
have no clue what the hell they're
talking about because they've never
actually spent any time experiencing
that we have lots of men who like to
play dress up and you know buy
themselves guns with all sorts of
accoutrements that they put on uh you
know to pretend that they're they're
tough that's the force of imagination
real soldiers don't do that as a matter
of fact real soldiers typically are not
all about being super buff or anything
like that or having the latest equipment
they're about accomplishing their
mission and Kings rulers likewise if
they have genuine power they don't have
to rely upon the imagination the way
that say you know what we're calling
magistrates and Physicians and and
doctors do so you know this is a pretty
interesting indictment of reasons
capacity to lead us to the true The Good
The Beautiful the just which imagination
often plays a very great role in and so
we have to be quite careful Pascal
things not to be swept along so easily
by custom by habit into this entire
imaginary realm that is set out for us
we can't simply say oh I'm going to put
that aside and only reason for me either
we have to find some way of managing
with both of these